Hello.
Welcome to Breaking the
JavaScript Speed
Barrier with V8.
My name is Daniel Clifford.
I'm the tech lead and manager
of the V8 team.
If you'd like to follow along in
the slides, there's a link
here on the first slide.
It might help for you in the
back rows to read the smaller
fonts in some of the
code slides later.
I'd like to talk to you today
about optimizing the
performance of your
web application.
Now this could mean a lot of
different things to a lot of
different people.
This could mean optimizing your
WebGL code to get more
frames per second in the game.
This could mean reducing the
number of network round trips
in a client server
application.
But what I'd like to talk to
you about today is Raw
JavaScript Execution Performance
with V8, the
JavaScript engine inside
of Chrome.
The V8 project has recently
moved to the development
center, the Google Development
Center in Munich, Germany.
And as you may know, Germany is
the home of the Autobahn.
And what you may not know is the
Autobahn is not actually a
single stretch of road from
Hamburg to Munich that runs
straight through the middle
of the country.
But rather it's a network
of roads.
And these days, most
of the Autobahn
actually has a speed limit.
But there are still a few
stretches of the road that
don't have any speed
limit whatsoever.
And you can go as fast as you
want, as fast as you can.
And so, as a resident of Munich
and a resident of
Germany, I feel especially
qualified to speak about
moving at speeds that would get
you ticketed here in the
United States.
You might ask the question, who
cares about performance?
JavaScript performance
is fast enough.
This is something that only game
developers need to worry
about, or the developers
of highly interactive
applications.
But I'm here to tell you that
you should care about
performance.
Everybody who develops a web
application should care about
performance.
And the reason is, is that
JavaScript performance matters.
It still matters.
It's not just about making
your current
application run faster.
It's about enabling things that
you have never been able
to do in the past.
Every cycle that you win back
when you do performance
optimization, you can invest
in something new that you
haven't been able
to do before.
An interesting comment about
these pictures, they were
taken on the same street,
only a few feet away.
I think it's interesting that
in the same place, given a
slightly different perspective,
you can have a
completely different
view of the world.
So let's see.
Let's talk about breaking
the speed limit today.
I'd like to use a checklist as
the basis of how you optimize
your web application.
It's a relatively
straightforward model.
But it's very powerful.
And the first step of the
checklist is to make sure you
are prepared before you
have a problem.
This is the piece that is
the most expensive.
This is the one that takes
the most amount of time.
And I'll be spending the
most amount of time
talking about it today.
But this is the one that you
have to do to make the second
two steps possible at all.
The second step is to identify
and understand the crux of
your problem.
And if you know how
a system works.
If you prepare before you go
into the second step, it makes
it much easier to find
your problem.
The third step, you
fix what matters.
And hopefully this is the step
that's actually really easy
after you've done
the first two.
Now, this is a relatively
simple model.
But, like I said, it's
very powerful.
And you can even apply it to
real world situations.
So I'd like to tell you a story
about using the checklist.
And I like to do recreational
mountain climbing.
I'm not very good at it.
But I have a friend
who is very good
at it, Michael Stanton.
And he's taught me
everything I know
about mountain climbing.
And I trust him on
the mountain.
I trust him with my life.
And that's how we found
ourselves in the summer of
2010 up here.
And it was a beautiful day.
We'd been on the mountain
all day.
We hadn't seen another soul.
We had the whole mountain
to ourselves.
And we were two rope lengths
from the top, from the summit.
We were almost there.
And I was belaying Michael.
I was making sure that if
he were to fall that
I would catch him.
And he was leading ahead.
And he climbed ahead of me
around a corner, out of sight.
And I heard him struggling with
a particularly tricky
climbing problem.
Then I heard two sounds that I
will never forget in my life.
And the first one was the
percussive sound of a rock
coming loose.
And the second sound was the
sickening thud of that rock
hitting Michael.
He fell.
I called his name.
But all I heard was silence.
I realized in that moment that
I had a performance problem.
And the checklist that I just
presented to you would be the
key for me to get out
of that situation.
I had to be prepared before I
ever got on that mountain.
I had to make sure to identify
the problem that I had in that
very moment, the key
problem, so that I
could fix it quickly.
Somebody's life could
depend on it.
Now, I hope you never are in a
situation like that, that your
life depends on applying
the checklist.
So why don't we go to an
example, which talks about a
less life threatening
performance problem.
Let's talk about JavaScript.
So I have put together a sample
problem that I'd like
to talk about throughout the
course of this talk.
And it is a toy problem that
I've come up with.
But I think it's representative
of some of the
things that--
some of the performance problems
that you might face
in your own code.
And the problem is to compute
the 25,000th prime.
Pretty simple algorithm here,
you start at one.
You count up.
And you take each candidate
number.
And you look in a list of primes
that you're maintaining
and see if any of those primes
can be divided into that
candidate number.
And if it can, then
the candidate
number is not a prime.
If none of the prime numbers go
into that candidate number,
then we have a new prime
and we add it to list.
And I wrote some code in
C++ and in JavaScript.
Don't sweat the details
of this code.
I just wanted to show you
that it's about the
same amount of code.
And I tried to do a pretty good
job of porting the code
from JavaScript to C++.
So it does the same thing.
And then what I did is I
actually ran the code.
I compiled the C++ code
with GCC and ran it.
And you can see it took about
three seconds to compute the
25,000th prime.
Then I took the JavaScript
code.
And I didn't run
it in browser.
What I did was I took the
debugging shell that's
available as part of the V8
open source code project.
And I compiled that and ran
the JavaScript with the
debugging shell.
The debugging shell makes
it possible for you to
concentrate on JavaScript
specific problems.
So for this presentation, I'll
refer to the debugging shell
in most of my examples.
You'll see that when I ran the
prime code in JavaScript, it
took 15 seconds.
So JavaScript's about five
times slower than C++.
That's not so bad, right?
Of course it is, yeah.
So I just made a big mistake.
I've told you about
this checklist.
And I just completely
ignored it.
I was not prepared.
I don't have enough information
to make judgment
about whether my code is bad or
good, whether that number
is something I should
expect or not.
I didn't even try
to analyze any
potential performance problem.
And I didn't even get anywhere
close to fixing any problem.
I'd like to show you
how V8 has improved
since Chrome came out.
This is V8's score on the V8
benchmark, version seven.
And you can see that it's
got a lot better
since we launched Chrome.
And we're now at the position
with V8 that we can actually
make a comparison against the
performance of C and C++ code.
You can expect to be in the
ballpark for certain code.
So don't give up here.
When you're in the same
situation, where you say,
we're slower than C++.
Or I'm slower where
I want to be.
Don't just give up.
Apply the checklist that
I presented to you.
And see how far you can get.
Demand that your application
is faster.
So how much faster do you
think we can get the
JavaScript code to run?
Who here thinks we can do it--
we can get it three and
a half times faster?
All right, we've got
maybe 5, 10 people.
35 times?
Takers?
OK, also a couple of people,
I know you know
how this game works.
350 times?
OK, one person, the V8 PMs.
[LAUGHTER]
3,500?
All right, we've got to get at
least one brave taker here.
So I think the most votes
were for 35 times.
Let's apply the checklist and
see how far we can get.
Now I told you the first step
was to be prepared.
And this means we're going to
dive into some technical
details of V8, so you can
understand how it works.
So fasten your seat belts.
This is where things get
a little bit racy.
So what does prepared
mean for V8?
I mentioned this before.
You need to understand
how V8 optimizes
your JavaScript code.
You need to understand how V8
actually works so that you can
help it optimize your code.
Because once you understand how
V8 works, then when you
actually write your JavaScript
code, you can keep those
things in mind and make sure
that you don't make some of
the mistakes that
will fool V8.
Make sure you learn the tools
that are available to you.
There's some great tools in
Chrome, the dev tools.
And V8 has some built-in tools
in the debugging shell that
can really help you understand
what's going on in your
JavaScript and help you
make it better.
All right.
So the first thing I'd
like to talk to you
about is hidden classes.
So JavaScript doesn't
have explicit types.
And this presents a bit of
a challenge to a language
implementer, because type
information is very valuable
in specializing generated code
to be very efficient.
And if you don't have that type
information, it makes it
much more difficult.
And it's hard to gather this
information efficiently and
quickly when you're compiling
JavaScript code because
compilation is part of
the execution time of
a JavaScript program.
Every cycle that you spend
compiling a JavaScript script
before you execute it is a cycle
longer than it takes to
actually get to doing
the work.
So we have to find a way
to get executing
code as fast as possible.
And it makes it difficult to do
expensive reasoning about
types at compilation time.
And that makes it extremely
difficult to get it close to
the performance of C++.
However, there are
some tricks.
Hidden classes help make V8
run JavaScript faster.
V8 internally creates hidden
classes for objects at run
time, not at compile time.
And that's how we get around
the problem of compiling
upfront, getting the information
upfront, because
we gather the hidden class
information as we go.
And here's a key insight.
And this is one that we'll
repeat throughout the
presentation.
Objects with the same hidden
class can use the same
optimized generated code.
And that means if you help teach
V8 through the way that
you structure your code, which
object has the same hidden
class, you can help it to
generate optimized code for
those cases.
I'd like to show you
how this works in
a very simple example.
So I've got a constructor
function here
for an object point.
And I'm going to instantiate
it twice.
And let's see actually what
V8 does behind the scenes.
So the first time the
constructor gets called, V8
creates a new hidden class.
So what you see here is-- on the
right hand side-- is you
see the new point object.
The first entry in the point
object is a hidden class to an
empty point hidden class.
And as we assign to the members,
in point, what V8
does is actually realizes, ah,
you're changing the hidden
class by adding a
member to it.
And we create a new
hidden class.
And the point object
gets assigned to
this new hidden class.
And if we had another member--
in this case y--
we get yet another
hidden class.
And you see what happens here
is that not only does V8
create new hidden classes as
new members are added.
But it keeps track of what had
to happen to get from one
hidden class to another one.
So you see we went from empty
point object to a point object
with an x, to a point object
with an x and a y.
And that's important because the
second time that we call
the point constructor, this
hidden class structure is
already there.
And as the code is executed to
add the members x and the
members y, you'll see
that the object also
gets new hidden classes.
But it gets the same hidden
classes that we created the
first time through.
So that at the end, we actually
have P1 and P2 having
the same hidden class.
The problem is, is that if we
add a member to P2 that we
haven't added to P1--
after the fact, outside
of the constructor--
what happens is that we
create yet another
hidden class for P2.
And it is different from
the class for P1.
So they are now-- we're not able
to use the same optimize
code for both of
those objects.
So be aware that by doing
something like this and
creating hidden classes, you're
defeating some of the
optimizations that V8 can do.
I'd like to talk about speed
traps to avoid in this
presentation.
For the most part, all of the
advice I'm going to give you
today is something
that is eternal.
You can assume that the tips
that I give you today you can
use forever, except for a couple
of cases where I'll
say, this is something that's
temporary, something that
we're working on and we're
trying to make better.
So let's get to the first speed
trap, which is make sure
to initialize all members in
your constructor functions.
This comes from the example I
just showed you, which is you
need to teach V8 which hidden
class objects should have
after they're constructed.
And the way to do that is by
putting all of the member
initialization in
the constructor.
Always initialize object members
in the same order.
This follows from that example
that I gave you.
If you add members in different
orders, you create a
different tree of
hidden classes.
And at the end, you'll have
objects with two different
hidden classes that can't use
the same optimized code.
Next thing I'd like to talk
about are numbers.
So because we don't have a lot
of type information in
JavaScript, we have
this dilemma.
We want to be able to generate
code that can handle all
possible different values, all
different possible types.
But you want to be able
to have an efficient
representation of numbers.
And how do we do this?
Well, we use a technique
called tagging.
So inside of V8 we pass
around values of
32-bit numbers and objects.
But we want to be able to
use the same 32 bits
to represent both.
And that way we can have one
code path that can handle, in
many cases, the objects
and integers.
So what we do is we use
the bottom bit.
And each of the values have
a special meaning.
If the bit is set, it's
an object pointer.
If it's clear, it's what we
call small integer or smi.
And that's a 31-bit
signed integer.
Now if you have a numeric value
that you're passing
around, assigning to a member
that is bigger--
it's a numeric value that's
bigger than 31 signed bits--
then it doesn't fit in
one of these smis.
And we have to create what's
called a box for it.
We box the number.
We turn it into a double.
And we create a new object to
put that number inside of it.
And what follows from that is
the next speed trap to avoid,
which is make sure, whenever
possible, you use 31-bit
signed numbers for performance
critical calculations.
Because if you exceed 31 signed
bits, we will have to
convert it to a double value.
Now there's some optimizations
that we have that doesn't make
it as bad as it seems.
But there are cases where that
process causes an allocation.
And that means that some
mathematical operations can
cause allocation.
The next thing I'd like to
talk about is arrays.
This brings some of the elements
together of the
previous two sections.
In JavaScript, you can have
very large arrays.
And you can have arrays that
are sparse, that don't have
every element inside of them.
And so V8 actually has two
different methods to handle
two different types of arrays.
The first one is
fast elements.
And fast elements, they have
a linear storage buffer.
And V8 uses them if the
set of keys for the
array is very compact.
If that's not the case-- so you
have a very sparse array--
then it uses a different
format, which
is dictionary elements.
Fast elements, linear buffer,
very fast and
efficient to access.
Dictionary elements,
it's a hash table.
Much more compact but
also more expensive
at run time to access.
Kind of obvious here, if you
want to have your arrays be
very fast, make sure that
V8 uses fast elements to
represent them.
And the way to do this is to
make sure that your keys start
at zero and that they're
contiguous.
So don't create an array
and start using
index number 25,000.
Start at zero and go up.
Also, don't allocate really
large arrays that you're not
going to use everything in.
So if you allocate an array with
65,000 elements and you
only use the first five, V8
thinks, well, that's a very
sparse array, and will switch
into dictionary mode, which
means the access of the elements
will be slower.
Don't delete elements
inside of arrays.
Same principle here, because
when you delete elements, it
makes the key set sparse.
And it can lead to V8 switching
the elements to
dictionary mode.
Don't load from uninitialized
or deleted elements.
This is an important one.
It's easy to get wrong.
Here's an example.
Your code will work.
You won't notice.
And it won't make a difference
in the output.
However, it will make
things a lot slower.
So here's an example of
doing exactly this.
I have a loop here that
accesses an array.
And it uses the or equals
operator, which means it takes
the existing value in the array,
ors it to something and
then writes it back.
But the first time that you do
that, you're accessing an
empty array.
And when you do that, the
JavaScript spec says, that's
an undefined value.
But that's OK.
It can be converted to zero.
And it's exactly what
it does here.
It converts that zero to do the
or equals and then stores
it back in.
But that process of conversion
means that this operation has
to do more checking.
And it's more expensive.
And by simply initializing the
value before you use it--
that's the second
example here--
you can make your code,
in this case,
about twice as fast.
So what about arrays
of doubles?
Remember I talked about tagging,
that we have to wrap
double numbers inside
of special objects.
So if you have an array of them,
doesn't that make it
expensive because each element
has to have this wrapper
object to store the
double value.
Well, there's a trick that we
can use there too as well.
So we have a mechanism
called unboxing.
When you unbox a double, you
take the 64-bit IEEE number
inside of this double object.
And you take it out.
And you put it into
a linear buffer.
So what we can do is track in
the hidden class of an array
the types of elements that are
contained in the array.
And if the array contains
only double
values, it becomes unboxed.
And what that means is that it
takes all of those numbers out
of the heap objects, out of the
wrapper objects, and lays
them out in a linear
buffer of doubles.
But again, it's only if there
are double numbers
inside of the array.
This causes the hidden
class change.
Generally, that's good because
if you convert the double
numbers into a flat buffer--
if you have array of doubles
and it's in a flat
representation, it's very
efficient to access that.
And when you store into it,
it doesn't require any
allocation.
But you must be aware that
converting between the array
that's boxed and unboxed
has a cost.
And it changes the
hidden class.
And careless manipulation of
arrays can lead to a lot of
extra work through this
boxing and unboxing.
I'll give you an example
of that.
Here's a pretty simple
snippet of code.
I create a new array.
And I sign a bunch
of values to the
first couple of elements.
Looks like there's not a whole
lot of work to do here.
But because I create an empty
array, the initial
object that I have--
you'll see--
doesn't actually have
any elements at all
because it's empty.
So the hidden class says,
hey, I'm an array.
And I'm optimistically going
to assume it contains smi
values and that I'm not going to
have any deletes, no holes.
We can do that because
the arrays empty.
So it's actually a
true statement.
It only has smis because
it has nothing in it.
What happens when we assigned
the first element of the
array, because we didn't have
a backing store for the
elements yet, we have
to allocate it.
And by default, we allocate
a buffer that has
room for four elements.
Now that the backing store is
actually there, we can store
the first element in here.
And, again, this is stored as a
smi, as one of these compact
31-bit signed integers.
And now that we have space, we
can also assign the second
element, also not a problem.
However, the next assignment
assigns a double value.
And what this does is forces
V8 to convert the format of
the backing store, because we
can't store a double value
directly into the array.
But what we could do is we could
convert the existing
integer values to doubles.
And then, with the unboxed
version of this array, we
could store the 0.5 value.
And that's exactly
what V8 does.
It reallocates a new buffer.
This time each of the elements
slots is 64 bits.
It converts the existing small
integers into double values.
And then it assigns the 0.5
to the third element.
You'll also notice that a hidden
class change happened
here, because what we did
is added a double value.
So it's no longer true that
the array only has smis.
We now have doubles in there.
That means that the hidden
class has to be changed.
It causes a hidden
class change.
Something similar happens when
we try to assign true.
So true, there are certain
objects in JavaScript which
are kind of oddballs.
We actually call
them oddballs.
True, undefined, null, they
are not really objects.
But they kind of act
like objects.
But they're certainly
not numbers.
So when I assign true to the
third element or the fourth
element here, it causes another
allocation because we
can no longer represent this
new value in this unboxed
double array.
So we have to convert it back
into its tagged format, which
means converting the elements
that can be represented as
smis back into smis.
It means reboxing the
double value.
And now we have a backing store
that we can actually
store the true value in.
That's a lot of work.
This is a very short
piece of code.
But we did four allocations,
two array, two hidden class
changes for just a couple
lines of code.
There is a better way.
If you use an array literal,
this is a hint to V8 upfront
what the values are going to
be inside of the array.
And given this example here, we
have a single allocation.
All of this can be done
in one allocation.
The correct backing store format
can be selected at
compile time.
And we don't have all of these
conversions in the
initialization of the array.
So touched on this already.
Speed trap, make sure, wherever
possible, you
initialize arrays with array
literals, especially for fixed
size, small arrays.
Also for small arrays, make
sure to preallocate them
before you use them.
Now, again, this is different
than large arrays.
Large arrays, remember, more
than 65,000 elements, you want
to make sure you grow as you go
so that you don't go into
dictionary mode.
For small arrays, even if
they're not completely filled,
even if they're small, if
they're sparse, if they're
small, V8 will use fast
elements for them.
But only if you allocate the
correct size will you be able
to avoid allocations when you
go from an empty array and
store the first element
into it.
Don't store non-numeric values
in numeric arrays.
So if you have an array of
double values, V8 can generate
very good code for manipulating
those values, for
those double values.
But if you put an object into
the array, we have to box
everything again.
And the code that we generate
is a lot less efficient.
OK, we've talked about hidden
classes and how they are an
important piece of
optimizing code.
Let's actually talk about how
we generate code in V8.
And this will maybe help you
understand a little bit better
why it's important to make sure
that you understand the
hidden classes.
So a V8 has two compilers.
The first one is called the full
compiler, because it can
actually implement the full set
of JavaScript features.
It generates good code
but not great code.
There's an optimizing compiler,
which I'll talk
about later, which produces much
better code for most of
the language.
The goal of the full compiler
is to generate code quickly.
I talked about before the fact
that any time you spend
compiling code is added to
your execution time.
So the full compiler strategy
is to get executing code as
quickly as possible.
It generates code that
is just good enough.
But because of that,
it basically
doesn't do any type analysis.
It doesn't know anything
about types.
And the way that it solves the
problem of implementing
operations on different types
efficiently is a technique
called inline caching
or inline caches.
And what inline caches do is
they gather type information
and run time.
And they optimize the
code as you go.
So you pay as you go.
And here's the way inline
caches work.
An inline cache, or an IC, is
a type-dependent small chunk
of code that knows how to do
an operation given specific
hidden class--
inputs of a particular
hidden class.
And what they do is they
validate the type assumptions.
They get a couple
arguments in.
They check to see if the hidden
classes are as they expect.
And if they are, then they know
that the code that is in
the IC is the optimal code for
implementing that operation.
If not, something
has to happen.
A new IC has to be generated
that can handle the new type
information.
And at runtime, if different
types are seen than what are
expected, then through
backpatching the code is
changed to use new specialized
code for the new
types that are seen.
I'll give you an example
of how that works.
Here's a fragment from the code
example at the beginning,
a prime number generator.
I'd like to take a particular
fragment of code there, which
takes an element from the
prime's array and checks
whether the candidate number is
divisible by that number.
And let's see what the
full code generator
does with this code.
Don't sweat the details.
I'm going to show some assembly
language here.
And it's not actually
important what
the details are here.
But I want to show the pattern
of what actually goes on here.
So each expression generates a
little chunk of code here.
You'll see that there's some
preparation code and then
there's a call out, a call to an
IC to actually do the work.
Likewise, for the array element
access, there is some
preparation work and then a call
out to the IC to do the
work, and for the [INAUDIBLE]
the same thing.
And the thing to notice here is
that, initially, the call
is to this initialize version
of the IC, because we don't
know what the types
are going to be.
We'll only know that
at run time.
And this is how it works
The code on the left here is a
small, almost impossible to
read version of the code
I just showed you.
And when we're executing this
code for the first time, and
we get to this IC, the first
IC, it calls an internal
routine that initializes
the IC.
It looks at what the arguments
are to that operation the
first time.
It checks the hidden classes.
And it says, oh, I know
how to do that.
I can generate specialized
code for that.
It does so.
And it backpatches the address
so that the next time you come
to the code, it does the
same thing again.
Assuming that the next time you
run, you're going to have
the same hidden classes, the
same types of objects, which
is an optimistic but usually
valid assumption.
It does the same thing for the
access of the array element
and for the [? lot ?]
operation.
And you'll see that each of
the ICs, all they are is
specialized code that know how
to do the specific operation
for a given set of object
types that are input.
This makes a big difference
in performance.
And this is why you need to
understand how some of this
stuff works with hidden classes,
because if you get it
wrong, you don't actually get
the performance improvement
that you will see or should see
when using ICs and then,
later, the optimizing
compiler.
So if you're running the sample
code that I showed at
the beginning to generate primes
without ICs, you get an
execution time that's
over 600 seconds.
When you turn ICs on--
don't have the optimizing
compiler on yet--
it makes a big difference.
So this is about a 20 times
speed improvement.
Now I'd like to introduce a
concept that we'll also come
back to later.
Monomorphic better
than polymorphic.
It sounds pretty complicated.
It isn't really.
Monomorphic operations are
operations that always work on
objects with the same
hidden classes.
So the first time you execute an
IC, we look at the argument
types for the operation.
We look at the hidden classes.
And we remember them.
And if the next time, through
those hidden classes, are the
same, it's monomorphic.
And if the next time they're
the same, it's still
monomorphic.
And it stays that way.
If at any time we see different
hidden classes for
the arguments to an operation
then it becomes polymorphic.
And it turns out that
monomorphic operations are
easier to optimize.
Or the code that we generate is
better than for polymorphic
operations.
So here's an example.
Let's say we have a function
add that adds two things.
And if I call that with two
integer arguments, it's
monomorphic.
However, if I call it again with
two string arguments, I
use the same operation--
this plus operation--
to work both on integers
and on strings.
And at that moment, it
becomes polymorphic.
And it becomes more difficult
for V8 to generate good,
really efficient code for
that plus operation.
So the speed trap to avoid here
is, wherever possible,
don't try to mix operations or
objects of different types in
operations at a particular
place in your code.
Prefer monomorphic code
to polymorphic code
wherever you can.
I'd like to talk about the
optimizing compiler.
We talked about the full
compiler, generates pretty
good code, gets executing
as fast as possible.
The optimizing compiler comes
back later for the code that's
really hot and recompiles
the hot functions.
Why does it do this?
Well, we've gathered information
about the types of
the objects that we're operating
on through the ICs.
And the optimizing compiler can
take that information and
make decisions about how to
optimize the code better.
What happens is the optimizing
compiler takes that type
information from the ICs.
And it speculatively inlines a
version of the operation based
on history, what it's seen
before in the ICs.
And it also means that it can
inline function calls that are
monomorphic.
This includes constructors.
This is actually a new feature
that we've added recently.
By enabling inlining, by
inlining this operation in the
optimize code, other
optimizations become possible.
And that's what the optimizing
compiler will actually do.
We'll go over this inline code
and find more opportunities to
make it faster.
Let's see how that works.
Again, a warning, here's
assembly code.
It's a very similar process to
the full code generator.
We generate a little piece
of code for each of the
expressions.
But this time, you'll notice,
as we generate each piece of
code, there's no call
at the end.
And in fact, when we're done,
it's straight line code.
So let's compare the performance
using the
optimizing compiler with the two
runs that we did before.
You'll see that with the
optimizing compiler, we're
even fast-- we're about
50 times faster than
the original code.
One thing that's really useful
is actually to find out which
functions are being
optimized by the
optimizing compiler in V8.
So there's an option you can
pass to the DHL that
will do just that.
It'll output the information
about which
functions get optimized.
However, there are certain
circumstances in which the
optimizing compiler can't
optimize a function.
This is called bailing out.
Or that's what we call
it, bailing out.
And the reason is there are
certain language features that
are just not supported yet by
the optimizing compiler.
The most obvious example
is try catch.
So if you have a function that
contains a try catch block,
the optimizing compiler, right
now, can't optimize that.
We hope to change that
in the future.
But until then, there's
a work around.
If you have performance
sensitive code that you'd like
to access from try
catch block, wrap
it in its own function.
Here's an example.
We have a function that's
performance sensitive.
We call that from the try piece
of a try catch block in
another function.
And by doing that, it allows
the optimizing compiler to
optimize the performance
sensitive function, even
though it can't optimize
the try catch block.
If you want to find out which
routines cannot be optimized
by the optimizing compiler and
why, there's an option you can
pass through the debugging shell
called trace bailout.
And that'll actually tell you
the functions that could not
be compiled and why.
The last thing I'd like to talk
about is deoptimization.
So the optimizing compiler
is pretty good
at generating code.
But there's a catch.
The optimizations that it
does are speculative.
It makes the optimistic
assumption that what it has
seen in the past is going to be
just like what it's going
to see in the future.
And that usually pays off,
because usually your code
keeps running like
it has before.
However, as with all optimistic
assumptions, that
may not be the case.
So when you're driving down the
Autobahn in Germany and
you're doing 200 kilometers an
hour, sometimes you're working
under the optimistic assumption
that you're not
going to be caught going
over the speed limit.
Remember, I told you there are
some stretches of the Autobahn
with a speed limit.
And you'll see out of the corner
of your eye, a red
flash from two of these things
on the side of the road.
And you've just been caught in
a speed trap, because your
optimistic assumption that you
were not going to be caught
speeding was wrong.
And what do you do?
You slam on the brakes.
You slow down to the
speed limit.
And you probably drive that
way for a while, slower.
There's a similar process
that happens in
optimized code in V8.
Invalid assumptions lead
to deoptimization.
When one of the assumptions is
no longer true, when one of
the hidden classes that you
get for an argument to an
operation is not what you
expected, then the specialized
code we generated is
no longer valid.
And we have to deoptimize.
What does that mean?
That means we throw way the
optimize code, because we know
the assumptions we made are just
simply no longer valid.
We resume execution in the
right place in the full
compiler code.
So we can continue
our execution.
But now it's at a slower speed,
because we're using the
version of code that is
good, but not great.
And a reoptimization of the
function might happen later,
because we're going to continue
to gather type
information in the ICs in
the full compiler code.
But for the short term, you're
going to run more slowly.
And what that means is that
deoptimization is something
you want to avoid.
And one way to do that is to
make sure that you don't
introduce hidden class changes
at a late time
running your code.
If you have types, object types
that you run in optimize
code, and V8 chooses to optimize
that code, and then
you later introduce new types,
that optimize code will
deoptimize.
And if you do that too
often, it has a cost.
You can tell the debugging shell
to output the routines,
the functions that it optimizes
on by passing the
trace deopt option to
the debug shell.
And it'll output which one it
deoptimized on and why.
Now most of you are doing web
development, I assume.
And therefore, you probably
want to be able to look at
your code in Chrome, as well
as directly in the DHL.
You can pass these options
that I've mentioned also
directly to Chrome using
the js flags option.
And the output will all show
up in standard out when
running Chrome.
OK, so that was the
be prepared part.
You now understand a little
bit about how V8 works.
Let's talk now about identifying
and understanding
problems using that knowledge.
What does that mean for V8?
First of all, ensure the problem
that you're looking at
is a JavaScript problem.
And this is sometimes
a little bit tricky.
You could use the dev tools in
Chrome to figure out where
you're spending time in
your web application.
It may look like JavaScript.
But be careful it might be the
case that there's also DOM
interaction.
So a really good way to do that
is, if you can take that
code that you think is the
performance bottleneck, pull
it out, and run it in the DHL,
that means it's pure
JavaScript.
Because the V8 project is just
JavaScript, it doesn't have--
it's integrated into Chrome.
But it, in itself, is just
the JavaScript execution
environment.
So if you can take that code and
run it with the DHL, then
you're pretty--
then you can analyze the
problems of JavaScript only
performance problem.
Collect metrics, measure
where you're spending
your time in the code.
And then locate the bottlenecks
and fix them.
So remember the example that we
had at the beginning, the
prime number generator.
If you run it in the shell and
pass an additional argument,
the dash dash prof argument, it
will run the program while
also sampling the execution
profile.
And it'll write a log that you
can then analyze with another
tool to see where you're
spending your time.
Before we look at that output,
where we're spending the time,
I'd like to go over briefly
again where we're spending the
time-- or what we're doing
in the program.
There's a couple important
functions here
in the prime generator.
First, we add a prime.
There's a function to add a
prime to the existing list.
There's a function that
actually tests whether
candidate number is divisible or
is divisible by one of the
existing primes.
And then there's the main
routine, which does the high
level algorithm.
It starts at one, goes up,
checks that number, whether
it's divisible by an
existing prime.
If not, it adds it to the prime
list, otherwise it goes
to the next number.
So what's our expectation?
The prediction is that we're
going to spend most of the
time in main.
And the reason for that is all
properties and functions are
monomorphic.
I wrote the code
to be that way.
All numeric operations
are smis.
We do a pretty good job
at optimizing those.
All the functions could
be inlined.
And there are no deoptimizations
or bailouts.
So my expectation is V8 is going
to do a really good job
of optimizing this code.
OK, so let's take a look at the
output and see where we
were spending our time.
So this is the output of
the tick processor.
It takes this output log
that's written with
performance data.
And it prints it in
a pretty format.
You see there's two sections
of the output here.
I've actually abridged this.
It's much longer.
But these are the important
parts for our profile here.
There's a JavaScript section.
This is the time we're spending
in generated code.
This is JavaScript code
executing in either the full
compiler code or
optimize code.
And then there's the C++
section, which is--
it's often the case that you'll
have C++ symbols in the
profile, because there's some
operations that we can't do in
generated code.
So we have to call out.
And as expected, we spend
a lot of time in main.
But it's actually about 25%.
You'll see there's three
columns here.
You see how many ticks you're
spending in that routine, in
this function.
And you'll see what the
percentage is of the overall
execution time.
But in this case
it's only 25%.
That's weird because I
expected a lot more.
V8 should do a really good
job on this code.
If you look at the other items
that show up in this profile,
this is weird.
We're spending time
doing a binary op
stub with an oddball.
An oddball, remember, I told
you those are things like
true, undefined, and null.
We don't have that
in our code.
That's kind of strange.
And we're spending
a lot of time in
library code doing modulo.
And that's kind of strange.
We should be able to inline
that as well.
I didn't expect that.
And then here's another one
that's kind of weird.
We're doing a conversion
from a number--
extracting--
we're taking a number
and boxing it.
And we really should be
generating very good code for
this program.
We're spending way too much time
doing something that's
not executing the JavaScript.
We're calling out
to libraries.
Something is very wrong
with this code.
So can you spot the bug?
The hint is, is that our array
is only of length prime count.
And we've actually exceeded the
end of the array in our
calculations.
And in both the C++ and
JavaScript version, it doesn't
make a difference
in the results.
And this is the thing that
you've got to watch out for,
is that even though you don't
see that there's a problem in
the results, the program's
a lot slower
than it needs to be.
So let's fix that.
Let's actually not do an
out-of-bounds array access.
And we'll re-run the profile
with the fix.
And you'll see this time, this
is what we were expecting.
That small change now makes us
generate much better code
because we're not accessing
outside of the array, getting
an undefined object-- this
oddball-- that we're trying to
do math on.
And now we're spending over
99% of our time in main.
This is what we expected.
So let's see actually how big of
a difference this makes on
the profile.
And when we run the code against
the C++ code again,
look at that.
C++ code, three seconds,
JavaScript, 1.8 seconds--
we're 60% faster.
Well, I forgot to optimize
the C++ code.
So when you do that, C++
is still faster.
But it's 17% faster.
It's ball park.
I have to take all of this
with a grain of salt.
I chose an example where
I knew V8 would do a
pretty darn good job.
More and more, we're optimizing
more cases that
makes V8 faster in
more situations.
So I expect in the future, we'll
get closer and closer.
But my point here is that
you need to make sure
to take a look at--
spend the time optimizing your
code to know where you're
spending your time, because
you can actually make your
code very fast.
So fix what matters.
We did a lot of time analyzing
our existing profile, tweaking
it, knowing how V8 works.
The last thing I'd like to point
out is, make sure you
don't forget to optimize
your algorithm.
So I have a new version of the
program here, where instead of
iterating over all the prime
numbers, I only iterate to the
square root of the candidate,
which is sufficient to
actually test for whether it can
be divided by one of the
prime numbers.
And if I run that result--
if I run that in the--
I time that, then you'll
see that now I'm
under 5/100 of a second.
And if we compare that with the
original version, which
was 15 seconds, that's
350 times speed up.
So, in summary, keep your
eyes on the road.
Be prepared.
Learn a little bit about
how V8 works.
Identify and understand the
crux of your problem.
And fix the thing
that matters.
You don't have a whole lot
of time to do performance
optimization.
Make sure that every
minute counts.
And my friend Michael is fine.
He had taught me how to tie a
special knot, which freed my
hands while he was hanging.
I was able to call on my cell
phone the mountain rescue.
Michael regained consciousness,
and I could
lower him down.
The helicopter came and took
us off the mountain.
So even though he had a couple
broken ribs, he's fine.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]